For the grace of God offers salvation to
all people teaching us to live Godly
life.
Jesus gave himself for us to redeem us and to
purify for himself.
A people that are his very own.
Well, good morning. Again Church. It is a joy to be a part of those every
time we do that and so it is something
that we hope encourages you and challenges you as well
just as as I try to do with every wedding that
I am a part of even just attending to say that
it's a reminder to me of my
commitment to my wife 17 and a half years ago. So
maybe as a parent that's just a reminder for you
as well.
But I'm excited to see so many new faces with us over the last few weeks.
And if that's you we hope that you feel at some
point when you're ready comfortable enough to be able to be known here. We want
to make that as simple as possible as more likely as
possible because there's something about connection something about
belonging to a people and being known by
that we want you to to get there now. It's
a step of faith. I realized for you who are new but again,
let us help you there's a QR code there come introduce
yourself to us. Either way. We want to help you.
But what we're doing is we're continuing our series through the book of Titus in
God's word. And so go ahead and turn there with me
late in the New Testament towards the end the book of
Titus.
This is the Apostle Paul's letter to his man
on Crete whose name was Titus which is
why it's called Titus very creatively as you're turning
there though many years ago. I went to
a Men's Conference because I
thought it would be helpful and it had it had
the lineup of the most popular speakers at the time.
But looking back I can identify some
problems.
That I now see some serious
errors.
In that multiple men on that platform now have disqualified
themselves from Ministry because they don't
match the character qualities of Elders that we saw from
Titus 1 verses 5 through 9 a couple weeks ago.
And they have fallen off in various ways,
but also at that conference.
There was an inordinate focus on on Manliness.
that now feels way more secular and
worldly then Godly
in Christ like
Now hear me. I'm thankful for those who are pushing and striving
to strengthen the resolve of men to stand up
and and stand in the Gap and protect and defend
and and bring Justice. Yes.
but when manhood devolves into a tough
guy contest
or that emotions are weak and you
can never cry.
Or some caricature that if you don't like
guns and trucks that you're not a real man.
Like that's where we've missed it.
And we've gotten off track somewhere.
And so what we're going to see in Titus 2 today is a
picture of true manhood.
As we look back at this scene in Crete.
We'll see the truth that Godly manhood is different than worldly. Manhood.
Godly Godly manhood is very different.
Than worldly manhood.
See in contrast thinking about that 2,000 years ago increase in
contrast to the way of that world that was being lived
in.
In contrast to those remember false teachers who were
who were Liars?
They were evil beasts.
They were lazy gluttons.
in contrast to all that what does God say a real
man looks like
What does God say a real man acts like?
Titus 2 verses 1 through 10 will show us
Now when I read this passage in a moment, you need to know that I'm planning to come
back through this same passage next week with a
focus on discipling women.
You'll see it kind of bounces back and forth. So we're going to take the same passage next
week about women. So let me
talk to you wives today.
Don't be elbow and your husband today through the
sermon. Did you hear what he said? You know, like that's not gonna
be good because it's coming back for you next week, right? So so it's
gonna be back and forth. God is an equal opportunity rebuker. So
we're both gonna have to learn and grow in these things. So
don't just just let the Lord work. Okay, right.
Plus you can't change anyone by nitpicking and nagging anyway,
and so let's let the Lord work, right?
Let's be humble enough to set our lives before this
both both our lives and our significant others
lives and other people in our lives. They're like, let's let's
be humble enough to say God. This is yours and you need to change this
you need to work on this including me.
Allowing that to happen humbling ourselves before his
word.
So don't be elbow and but also women don't check out on this because because hear
me if you're not married.
And you want to be married?
What I hope you hear today are the character qualities of
a man. You should look for.
This is what you should be striving for praying for.
Maybe you're not married and you don't want to be married. That's fine. Look
for ways to encourage the men in
your life towards these kinds of things.
and then wives
look for how you can pray for your husband.
How you can lift him up in these ways as you'll see in
God's word.
Let's look now at Titus 2 verses 1 through
10.
But as for you, that's remember Paul talking
to Titus in contrast to what he just said
about the false teachers. He says but as for you Titus
teach what Accords with sound Doctrine?
Older men are to be sober-minded dignified self-controlled.
Sound in faith in love and instead fastness.
Older women likewise are to be reverent in Behavior
not Slanders or slaves to much
wine. They are to teach what is good? And so train
the young women to love their husbands and children to be self-controlled pure
working at home kind submissive to
their own husbands that the word of God may not be
reviled.
Likewise urge the younger men to be self-controlled.
Show yourself in all respects to be
a model of good works.
And in your teaching show Integrity dignity and sound speech
that cannot be condemned.
So that an opponent may be put to shame having nothing
evil to say about us.
Bond servants are to be submissive to their own masters and everything.
They are to be well pleasing not argumentative not pilfering
or stealing not show but
showing all good faith.
So that in everything they may Adorn the
doctrine of God our savior.
God we need you.
This is your word speaks directly to
that scene in creat, but we know it speaks to us today.
So give us ways to apply give us
ways to see give us ways to understand make us good soil
in our hearts to understand what you want for us
as men.
To support those around us those men in our lives.
That you might show the world something different.
Thank you, Lord.
Holy Spirit work in us today in Jesus Authority
we pray amen.
So if you remember from the end of chapter one last week.
The false teachers were upsetting whole families.
That's the way it says it.
They were teaching false things and it was it was
it was affecting families. And so they it was
affecting the way families were supposed to behave the way they were
supposed to interact the household codes. You might say and so here in
Titus 2, there's a corrective to that.
Titus needs to hear what Paul says
that the false teachers teaching this Paul says here's what
a Godly household looks like.
Here's what kind of Lifestyle matches healthy Doctrine.
The gospel, here's what it looks like because remember this is this is
Titus. We're talking about his very own the church is
but we are so so we submit Our Lives including
our families to what God wants.
So what does healthy manhood look
like then?
Let's examine what it looks like for the cretan Believers here,
but then how we can apply it to our lives today. What
is healthy? Manhood sound remember
that word sound means healthy. So we're talking Health here.
Well verse 2 and verse 6 are the two verses specifically given
regarding men in the church. The first ones to the
older men. The second one wants to the younger men.
Now here's just a side note in verse 2. The Greek
is doesn't mean old. Like you're not
old guys. It's actually aged like a
fine cheese. So think of that like if I
get all just like cheese, right? So anyway, but that's
what older men are to be and then what younger men
and the list for older men is much longer. Yes.
But remember it's assumed here that a
younger man will eventually be an older man.
So don't you think we should be pursuing this list
of the older men all men should be
pursuing what you see in the list for older men here.
That's what this list is look at verse 2 again. Let's read it.
Older men are to be sober-minded dignified self-controlled sound
and faith in love and instead fastness.
It's quite the list right? There's a lot of similar words in there a lot
of similar meanings. And so what I did is I summarized
them into three categories of healthy manhood.
Took all that right there and tried to summarize it down
into three simple words.
First that a healthy man is loving.
Healthy man is loving.
He says at the end an older man ought to be sound or healthy.
in love
That's the Greek word agape.
Very familiar word used in all of the
New Testament for love, especially for the
love. That is sacrificial that Jesus has for
his people.
Ephesians 5 verse 2 commands us to walk
in agape.
as Christ Agape us
and gave himself up for us a fragrant
offering and sacrifice to God.
So Christ his love was
a sacrifice. And so what you see here is
a true picture of what Love Actually is. We've
said it before here that love is willing self-sacrifice for
the good of someone else even when they don't deserve it
and even when they can never pay you back.
It's it's love that is giving so a
Godly Man is someone who is healthy in the
way. He loves others.
Sacrifices for others a sacrificial lifestyle
generously giving to those in your
life.
Just think of the parable of the Good Samaritan that Jesus told in Luke chapter 10.
In that story there were religious people who passed by
this man who'd been beaten up on the side of the road.
Cross to the other side, but the Good Samaritan had
compassion for him.
And not only felt something but he he picked
the man up. He bandaged his wounds. He took care
of him at the hotel. He paid for that man to stay
there. As long as he needed to stay there. That was Jesus saying this
is what love looks like.
Not just that he felt compassion, but he actually did
something about it. That's how you love your neighbor. Jesus
says.
That's the picture Jesus gave and so it's not just a feeling.
And it's not just dad's. Listen, it's not just saying I love
my kids.
It's actually sacrificing and
dying to yourself.
As a living sacrifice for others.
you remember the the cretans were described as
Liars
evil
that word Beast is like animal impulses. They're
led by their flesh. They're led by just whatever drives them
at that moment, right? They're lazy gluttons.
So to be think about this to be a sacrificially loving
man.
in that culture
would have been in direct contrast to
the way of the world.
But hear me it's in direct contrast to the way
of our world today too, isn't it?
Because most everything in our lives as
men says go get yours.
Take what you want.
live for yourself
Go do your thing, right? All this culture breeds
selfishness?
When God's call to men in Ephesians 5 is
to give is to sacrifice like
he did for us.
Later Ephesians 5 when he's talking about marriage, he says
husbands Agape your wives.
As Christ Agape the church and gave
himself for her.
How did Christ love the church he gave himself?
He died for the church.
Husbands do that for your wife.
So Godly Man a healthy man is loving.
in the way God describes loving
but Titus 2 also says that a healthy
man is faithful.
He's faithful.
Again here at the end of that verse it says that he is
sound or healthy in faith.
and instead fastness
that first there's a deep faith in this man.
a trust in the Lord
a trust that keeps one Rock Solid
in fact steadfastness is one of the greatest qualities
that I admire in older men.
There was a man in the church that we served out in
Weatherford Oklahoma my first church out of Seminary.
a man named Toby Hawkins
Who was the steadiest man that I've ever met?
You know those people right that just they're the same
every day, you know what you're gonna get from them and they are constant everything
bad happens. Everything good happens. They are
steady.
The other word that the end of verse 2 is similar, it's steadfastness
right that there's faith and steadfastness it
that word means the ability to stand up
under pressure.
to hold out under difficulty
like when you're getting pressed you're getting pushed you're able
to stand nothing changes.
It's easy to stand when there's no wind on you. But when there's a 70 mile-hour
Gail, it's a little harder, right but steadfast means I'm standing
still no matter what's coming. That's steadfast.
Patience endurance fortitude perseverance. Those
are similar words to steadfastness.
Jonathan Edwards, some of you might know that name he modeled
this quality back in 1750.
Jonathan Edwards, one of the greatest theologians in American history.
He was fired after serving
over 20 years at the church in Northampton,
Massachusetts.
And there was a man in the in the precedings that happened is like
a week-long deal a man named David Hall he participated
in it and here's how he recorded the way Edwards responded.
To the news he had been fired.
Here's what David Hall wrote that faithful witness talking about
Jonathan Edwards that faithful witness received the
shock unshaken.
I never saw the least symptoms of displeasure in
his countenance his face the
whole week.
But he appeared like a man of God.
Who's happiness was out of the reach of his enemies and
whose treasure was not only a future but
a present good.
overbalancing all imaginable ills
of life
Even to the astonishment of many who could
not be at rest without his dismission.
Steady, right?
He knew his treasure was something out there that nobody
else could see he's like, what can you do to me?
20 years of faithful Ministry and he gets fired and
he's okay.
Steady faithful to the Lord first and
foremost because he knew his call was to preach the gospel. He's like,
well, I can do that here or there wherever and he knew that was what his
primary task was. His trust was in
the Lord's hands, but then also steadfast and
confidence in daily life.
No matter what wind comes he's steady.
That's how men should be.
Never to the point of arrogance.
That's not what we're talking about.
But think about Jesus when he was in the garden how he resolved.
I prayed this he said father not my will but your will
be done.
Meaning I am in for whatever you have and I'm
gonna stand strong on it.
No matter the cost no matter how painful it is.
I'm Yours God.
steadfastness
You see how different that is in the way of the world.
Because people all around us.
are constantly lying
they're pulled to and fro by these animal impulses that
we have in our flesh. You see that every day around
us. You see gluttons overdoing everything in
our society.
But when Godly men are steady.
Are unmoved even by difficulties in
life?
the world takes notice
the world notices
that kind of Faith stands out.
In a world that's gone crazy.
There's one more category here in Titus 2 regarding healthy manhood.
It's being self-controlled.
Loving faithful self-controlled.
Now you catch something here that this was the only one
Paul mentioned for the younger men in
verse 6.
I'll talk about that more in a second. But but
when you think about what he said to the older men
in verse 2
much of what he wrote to them could be
summarized by this phrase self-controlled.
I mean just look at it. He said sober-minded.
That means you're able to clearly think now we know the term
sober and in light of being drunk when you're drunk with
alcohol. You can't clearly think so he's saying being sober-minded it
clear judgment that you can understand the world
and situation you're facing.
dignified
That's a word that means worthy of respect Noble.
Think of those cretans who are lazy gluttons.
Like if you're a lazy Glutton if that's what you're marked as you're not going
to be respected, right?
But really that's that's all summarized by self-control.
You have self-control in your thoughts. You have self control and your actions. Are
you able to manage?
And really self-control is at the root of so many parts
of our lives.
That's why he calls it out for the young men
as the only thing.
Like that's the root of all of these other things.
By the way, women listen self-control is not just a male thing, right? This
is for all of us.
Self-control even says it to the women we'll talk about this next week. He says
it in there in verse 5 to be self-control. So this
is a human thing.
Not just men.
But listen guys, I'm speaking as a man. Listen
guys, if you can get this one figured out early.
Man, you're gonna win a lot more of the battles along the way.
Sadly, that's not my story.
as a Young Man
I was out of control in some ways.
When I would be considered a young man here.
I don't need to go in all the details of it, but maybe in maybe in
this moment today. You're feeling that you're out
of control in some area of your life.
It's a helpless feeling, isn't it?
And you know things are just going way off
track.
And you almost feel like you can't do anything about it.
Maybe it's
For you, maybe you're out of control in your finances.
And you're just spending money to try to find significance and
feel some void in your life through spending money.
Or maybe it's in your relationships and it's just out of control. And so
what you do is you run away from everything because you don't want to get hurt.
Or maybe what's out of control in your life is food.
We're pornography or video games or or whatever it is.
You can sense that out of control this in your life,
but
hear me here when we talk about self-control. I'm afraid
that we often respond to that feeling of being out of
control by getting self-control wrong.
See, here's what I mean by this.
We hear the word self control all of us have grown up
in this situation like you need self-control and and what we do though
with that.
Is we run to rules?
We start to put fences around those
rules.
We doubled down on things. We try harder in
this like we White Knuckle it you know what I
mean by that we squeeze really hard your knuckles turn white you
try and to get this right to make
it happen.
But it doesn't work does it?
I know it doesn't work.
I've been there.
Then what happens here? Here's what happens. We we trial these things we build
defenses and then we fail again and we run
and hide and shame.
But listen, all of that that I was just describing that's false self-control
really in the end.
Because what you're doing, what I was doing is just managing a problem
that will eventually destroy you.
Trying to grip it with closed hands because you think
you have self-control over it.
Just just think about first think of those operative words
in that.
self
control
And we love control don't so so self. Like
that's what we're trying to brute force
it to happen.
and control
and manage this problem.
But the way of the Cross is different.
the way the cross
Is exposing it?
being humiliated
having the hard conversation about it.
Not trying to manage it and hide it and and keep it in the
closet back there. No, it's opening that door
to it. And listen. I've been there it is terrifying to
open your hands up and lose control
because then you don't know what's going to come on
the other side of that.
You have self-control you think I've got this. I know what
I can feel how this is gonna go even though it's out
of control still but you think you have control you open it up and
you're like, I don't know how they're going to respond.
When I confess that I don't know how they're going to
respond when I say that to the church. I don't know how they're going
to handle that. I don't know what that's going to lead to and
it's terrifying.
but in that moment of confession
that moment of vulnerability
that Holy trust in the Lord
what that brings is reconnection.
When you're gripping and hiding your disconnected, but
what that happens when you open it up reconnection happens
with God where you've you've been hiding away from him. And
now he brings you back. You come back to him and
it brings reconnection with others. There's no more secrets
between the two of you and so you are open meaning
reconnect.
You can come back to your father.
Through the shed blood of Jesus where you can
open your hands up and you know your sin and
your shame is covered and that in that you
find true self-control.
We might rename this.
new self control
Colossians 3 says put off the old man
put on the new self.
So when I talk in self-control like grip it make it forced it
into what you want it to be the new self-control is
you're submitting to how God wants to work in
you and change you.
And allow him to work in you right?
See, I don't know how the gospel of grace somehow
got Twisted into something that
forces you to try harder.
You understand what I'm saying about like.
Yeah, we're saved by grace, but then you better make it
happen the rest of your life.
What did Jesus say?
Matthew 11
:28 through 30.
Come to me.
All who labor and are heavy
laden. I will give you rest.
Take my yoke my my burden upon you
and learn from me for I am gentle and
lowly in heart and you'll find rest for
your souls.
For my yoke is easy in my burden is light.
Don't turn self control into something. It's not.
Remember self control Galatians 5
is a fruit of God's spirit within you.
He produces it in you and so
the only way you get it is by
abiding in him.
It's by by dying to
self opening your hands and letting him
have control.
of that situation of your whole life
and when you do that, you'll see your ability to
overcome Temptation grow and grow and grow.
Not because you've got it figured out and you've got it tried harder
to get there.
But because you've released it and said Jesus is yours.
So I know that all this is not a comprehensive definition of Godly
manhood.
But see how a loving faithful self-controlled
kind of life is so
different than the way of the world.
Like just imagine a bunch of men walking around our
church.
Living like that.
Leading their families like that.
Being single like that.
Like it is that not a powerful picture of
what God could do through men saying Jesus. We're
yours.
Our church would be better for that. Our homes would
be better for that. Our world would be better because of
that.
And so that's the picture of man, but here's the thing back in Crete.
They didn't have many if any good
examples of what that looks like.
Remember what cretans are?
Liars evil beasts lazy gluttons, that's all they were. And
so now they're like, okay, what does this look like Paul? So Paul
then calls Titus to be an example.
Titus is coming in kind of from the outside. He might have been from Crete but
but most likely he's he's been somewhere else for a while. He's coming back there and
he says Paul says to Titus you need
to set the pace man.
Find Elders who can set the pace, but you've got to do it.
That's what he says in verses 7 and 8 saying show yourself.
That's a singular word to tie to show yourself in
all respects to be a model of good works in your
teaching show Integrity dignity and sound speech that
cannot be condemned. So an opponent maybe put to
shame having nothing evil to say about us.
You see what he said show yourself.
Not pridefully not arrogantly.
They needed someone to be a model for them.
The Greek word there is two paws from which we get our
word type.
Like you type you see marks show up. It's the example of
Jesus seen even
in the Old Testament through Moses and these things like those look like Jesus
a little bit. That's the idea of type.
It's What's Happening Here? We needed someone to be an example. Like
in First Peter. 5:3 Elders are to be an example to
the flock. It's the same kind of idea.
so older men he says
Titus you do this older men though, but also women you
are also supposed to do this to be an
example.
To those who go behind you. This is all we're talking about we're talking about disciple making
That you just set an example. You live a life that someone can
follow say oh, that's what it looks like to follow Jesus. That's what
we're talking about here. He says to tie to show
yourself to be an example of the things God's designed
us to do.
They need to see it Titus. They need to see what it looks
like to follow Jesus.
And do it in a way that no one can speak badly. That's about
the the above reproach idea from chapter one, like do
it in a way that no one can criticize that you don't
actually do what you say you're doing
but hear me young people.
This is not just for the older women. Older men
to leaders in the church. Don't hear that that
is it because Paul also had a guy in
Ephesus. His name was Timothy.
Timothy is a young guy.
Similar to Titus in Crete. This is what Paul said
to Timothy in 1st Timothy 4:12. He says
let no one despise you for your youth.
but
set the Believers an example.
In speech in conduct in love in faith
impurity.
Doesn't matter how old you are.
Set an example.
But listen, the only way you can do that.
Is if you have been transformed by Jesus first.
Again, we're not saying try harder make you make sure you be an
example. We're saying be transformed by Jesus. So
you are an example. You cannot manufacture this kind of
Lifestyle.
It only happens. If God has put a
new heart and a new spirit inside you by faith
in his life death and Resurrection in your place.
That he's made you a new creation a new self control, right?
Where you remember? You're loved not because of what you
have done or what you have performed for him.
That he loves you.
Even before you could anyway earn it. He loves you
even when you were his enemy he loves you.
And when you remember that.
Now even even with the new heart, I understand. Yes, we're
going to to have our flesh still there. We're gonna fall into
temptation from time to time all of that. But in that
as we lean on the Lord, he works in
our lives. He changes us. He makes us new
which then allows you to turn around and be an example to those who are behind
you.
In the Journey of Faith now, I might say
behind you. It may be one step like you you're only
one step ahead of them. But but you know something they don't know.
You don't have to have a degree from Seminary to
be an example to be a leader to make disciples. It doesn't
demand that it all it demands is that you are taking steps forward
and someone's one step behind you.
And able to walk with you and follow you towards.
Jesus
And again, all of this plays out not just theoretically.
Not just in the church all this plays out in
Daily Life.
Right. This this is this is an example. We set not
just by talking about it in here. This is an example we set in
life.
Remember those false teachers the pagans and Crete.
They were living this completely opposite life. The Christian's
life was supposed to be set apart.
And notice Paul here in verses 9 and 10.
It seems like it's out of touch. It's out of like just
offshoot somewhere. No, he talks about these Bond
servants and verses 9 and 10.
This is one example.
Of how this worked out for a Christian, even if
they were a slave and had an unbelieving Master.
He's like saying in the worst case scenario this
still works.
Watch this look at verses 9 and 10 again.
Bond servants are to be submissive to their own masters in everything
there to be well pleasing not argumentative not
pilfering stealing but showing all
good faith. So that everything they may Adorn
the doctrine of God our savior.
He's like this is an example.
In contrast to other Bond servants
who would have been arguing who had been subversive who
would have been all kinds of Thieves.
He says Christian Bond servants.
If you're a Christian and you're in that situation you are to Adorn
the gospel.
The Greek word there is cosmeo where
we get the root word of cosmetics.
It's the word Adorn to make it in other words to make the
gospel of God as beautiful as possible.
It already is but we make it so attractive by
our lives that they're so
different that people are saying I want what you have.
What is it that you have that something so precious
to you?
And changed you so much. I want that.
So what Martin Luther said 500 years ago, he said because the
Lost cannot see our faith that's
internal right? It's a faith inside. He
says they ought to see our works.
Then hear our Doctrine and then they
might be converted.
They can't see what we believe.
But they can see our lives.
then they might listen and then they might
believe
that's his order of operation there.
And so listen men, this is again. We'll talk about next week
with women but men today.
Are you pursuing a Godly vision of manhood?
Or are you pursuing the world's Vision a manhood?
Hear me in all this. I'm not implying that that men should
be soft.
Men should be weak.
Because remember our ultimate example of this is Jesus.
The man who showed us strength under
control his entire life.
He wasn't weak. He wasn't soft.
He had all the strength and power in the in universe.
And he kept it under control the entire time.
See we need men to step up and bring Justice
and gladly assume responsibility in
life. Yes. We just better do that with
love and faithfulness and self-control.
That's how we go about that task. I mean just think about
how safe.
People would feel around you.
If these things marked your life.
If you're a known as a man who's loving and faithful and
self new self-controlled.
Your wife your kids your friends
your coworkers would feel safe.
Because that's who you are.
What an example of Jesus to those people?
So just think about analyzing yourself Psalm 139. Ask God
to show us our hearts analyze Yourself In
This Moment.
Do you lead with sacrificial generosity?
giving of yourself
Do you model faithfulness to God and to the
people that he is entrusted to you? Are you consistent and
faithful to them?
Are you rock solid stable when the Winds of
Life come your way. Are you are you steady?
And are you opening your hands with your lust your
Temptation? Whatever you opening your hands to
Jesus with it and saying this is yours.
If those things Mark you welcome to
manhood.
It's what it is.
It has nothing to do with how tough guy you are.
Or whether you like sports or guns or not, like
it has nothing to do with any of that stuff. You can go ahead and like that stuff.
There's nothing wrong with that. Just don't make those extra biblical
things your standard of manhood.
Like you're you're example in your mind should be Jesus not John Wayne.
Should be Jesus loving faithful self-control because
Godly manhood is different than worldly. Manhood.
It looks completely different. We've seen
it all day. So instead of pursuing the ways of
the crowds around us.
Let's set an example of what it means to pursue
Jesus with our entire hearts.
Leaning on the blood of Jesus when we fail
at that.
Because you will I will.
We need Grace. We need his love. We need his blood to cover
us. But also as we do that adorning the
gospel.
with a transformed kind of life